[Musik]
zdf heute live herzlich willkommen an
diesem dienstagabend
jetzt ist er wirklich zum greifen nah
der impfstoff gegen cupid 19 so könnte
das aussehen
am montag lässt wenn es denn so kommt
und danach sieht es im moment aus die
europäische arzneimittelbehörde ema den
bei contec impfstoff zu für europa und
damit auch für deutschland wenige
stunden später gibt die eu-kommission
ihr okay und das könnte bedeuten dass
tatsächlich rund um weihnachten herum
die ersten menschen in deutschland
geimpft werden können
dazu freuen wir uns heute abend wie
immer über ihre und eure fragen in die
kommentare oder wenn ihr die zdf- heute-
app nutzt bitte an die bekannte und hier
nochmal eingeblendete e mail adresse wir
sprechen darüber heute abend mit unserem
korrespondenten stefan leifert in
brüssel und mit dr till koch teil des
teams der infektiologie am uke in
hamburg ende also uke steht für
uniklinikum hamburg eppendorf
also sie wissen was gemeint ist und sie
zu hause hoffentlich auch herr doktor
drk verschiedene eu politiker sprechen
davon dass dieser impfstoff ein
weihnachtsgeschenk ist es dass für sie
auch sehen sie das auch so
ja auf jeden fall plant die letzte woche
auch wieder total spannend zu jemanden
der schon längere zeit in dem stoff
forschung arbeitet war das wirklich
ähnlich wieder ganz clever durch auch
schon total spannend weil es war ja so
das war schon so verlautbarungen gehört
hatten in form von 2
und was die wirksamkeit dieser drei
impfstoffe angeht also dieser drei voran
aber auf englisch sagt der impfstoffe
die am weitesten sind daten bis jetzt
immer über pressemitteilung und zu zwei
von diesen impfstoffen sind jetzt
tatsächlich die wissenschaftliche
arbeiten erschienen in fachzeitschriften
und die haben ganz spannende resultate
gezeigt und das war für uns in der
wissenschaft wirklich ein großer
unterschied und da bin ich sehr erfreut
darüber
bevor wir gleich in die details gehen
schauen wir mal an was genau geplant ist
wie es ablaufen könnte und wo im moment
bereits damit geimpft wird fix für pc's
zur immunität die briten machen es schon
seit einer woche die usa impfen seit
gestern mit dem stoff von biontech und
pfizer und auch in der eu steht der
stoff kurz vor der zulassung
unser ziel ist dass es noch vor
weihnachten eine zulassung gibt und dass
wir dann auch noch in diesem jahr
beginnen können zu impfen auch hier in
deutschland entscheiden muss am ende die
ema also die european medicines agency
das ist die zuständige europäische
arzneimittelbehörde
wahrscheinlich wird sie am 21 dezember
ihre entscheidung bekanntgeben
in den fabriken wird der impfstoff schon
jetzt im großen maßstab hergestellt
damit bei der zulassung direkt große
mengen bereitstehen bis zu 12 13
millionen dosen im ersten quartal
das ist aber eben der stand vierzehnter
zwölfter wenn es zusätzliche zulassung
von astra zenica zum beispiel gäbe oder
johnson johnson in diesem ersten quartal
hätten wir auch zusätzliche impfdosen
verfügbar das ist durchaus realistisch
insgesamt hat deutschland rund 300
millionen impfstoffdosen bei
verschiedenen herstellern bestellt
neben dem stoff von biontech und pfizer
sind noch weitere im endstadium der
erprobung könnten also bald zugelassen
werden meistens sind pro impfling zwei
dosen notwendig um maximalen schutz zu
erhalten
entsprechend wird es monate vielleicht
sogar jahre dauern bis ein so großer
teil der bevölkerung
dass die pandemie zum erliegen kommt das
wort impfling das kennen wir zwar aber
das werden wir in den nächsten tagen und
wochen wohl öfter hören und es ist ein
wort an das man sich gewöhnen muss im
täglichen nachrichten geschehen stefan
hier sind schon die ersten fragen im
chat aufgetaucht die ich gerne an dich
weitergeben würde gefragt so fragt zum
beispiel die über youtube wie
unterscheiden sich die
zulassungsprozesse in der eu von denen
in großbritannien oder den usa
die zulassungsverfahren in der eu die
sind nach einem ganz festgelegten
verfahren sortiert da geht es um die
frage der wirksamkeit der
verträglichkeit der langzeitwirkung und
da ist ziemlich streng festgeschrieben
was für studien und das für hürden was
für voraussetzungen erfüllt sein müssen
nun am ende eine genehmigung zu erteilen
die briten haben es haben jetzt einen
kleinen startvorteil gehabt weil sie
unabhängig von den anderen 27
eu-mitgliedern nach dem break für sich
selber entscheiden können wie sie so ein
verfahren gestalten und sie haben sich
für eine sogenannte notfall zulassung
entschieden also für eine die ein
beschleunigtes verfahren ist und die hat
den briten diesen vorsprung gesichert
der jetzt zwei oder drei wochen beträgt
der am ende aber was die bekämpfung der
pandemie in der großen fläche angeht
keinen großen unterschied machen wird
das zumindest sagt heute hier die eu in
brüssel
nun hat wenn ich das richtig verstanden
habe die frage nach dem
zulassungsverfahren vor allem auch einen
hintergrund bei der frage nach der
haftung und da gibt es auch eine frage
über youtube von pininfarina rossa wie
es die haftung für eine mögliche
gesundheitsschädigung geregelt der
produzent haftet nicht aber wer
lieferant der arzt der staat
gesundheitsamt fragezeichen das sind
fragen die glaube ich noch in der
klärung sind fragen der haftung kann ich
aus dem stegreif nicht beantworten aber
mich würde es wundern wenn das schon
abschließend geklärt ist zwischen eu
kommission die ja die verträge mit den
herstellern macht und machen wird sobald
die genehmigung da ist dann fragt auf
youtube im briger ist ein bisschen
länger das ist nicht nur eine frage ist
quasi ein kommentar da wird mit mühe und
not etwas gemacht um nachrichten wirksam
die ersten impfungen noch 2020 zu machen
bei den feiertagen lockdown und so
weiter wird die logistik den impfstoff
an circa 400 impfzentren allein in
deutschland auszuliefern schwierig und
ziel ist ja auch gleichzeitig alle 27
eu-länder zu beliefern
ob das was wird ist hier die skeptische
frage wie ist denn das jetzt geregelt
wie läuft das ab stefan also der
zeitplan ist so dass am 21.12 nächsten
montag in amsterdam bei der eu
zulassungsbehörde für medikamente eine
sitzung stattfindet die das kann man
glaube ich zu 99,9 prozent sagen eine
genehmigung für diesen impfstoff
erteilen wird dann vergehen ungefähr
noch einmal zwei drei vielleicht auch
vier tage die dann noch ins land gehen
für eine abschließende genehmigung der
eu-kommission hier hinter mir
die mitgliedstaaten müssen alle noch mal
zustimmen und dann geht's los und das
was dann passiert das liegt in der
verantwortung der mitgliedsstaaten also
das regelte an deutschland für sich
selber zum beispiel wie diese wege dann
stattfinden von den herstellern die den
impfstoff dann ab dem tag ausliefern
können bis hin zu den impfzentren in
deutschland ist das so geregelt dass der
bund verträge geschlossen hat zum einen
über die eu-kommission zum einen aber
direkt mit den herstellern
da gibt es jetzt eine bestimmte menge an
impfdosen die dann an dem ersten tag der
auslieferung zur verfügung stehen die
müssen dann unter ganz bestimmten
strengen bedingungen ausgeliefert werden
an die impfzentren die wiederum sind
ländersache
ja und wer dann zuerst geimpft wird und
wer in welcher reihenfolge das
entscheidet der bundestag und darüber
ist das letzte wort noch nicht
gesprochen aber pro wissen wir ja wie
das läuft zuerst sind die alten dran die
risikogruppen und so geht s dann
scheibchenweise weiter stefan wie wird
das denn in brüssel kommuniziert und
diskutiert denn die frage nach dem
impfstoff ist ja auch ein rennen gegen
die zeit
und wenn man sieht dass die zahlen hier
steigen die todeszahlen steigen in
deutschland
und die werden über die
weihnachtsfeiertage weiter ansteigen
wenn man sich die infektionszahlen jetzt
betrachtet und dann zeitverzögert die
sterberaten sich anschauen wird das
heißt jeder tag mit dem man noch nicht
impfen kann verliert man quasi menschen
leben wenn man das gesamtgefüge sich
anschaut wie geht denn die eu damit um
dass dieser impfstoff in einem
europäischen land nämlich in deutschland
entwickelt wurde
aber in anderen ländern heute bereits
geimpft wird und hier aber noch nicht
also in brüssel kommentiert man das mit
aus zwei richtungen die einen sagen
natürlich dass sicherheit auf jeden fall
vor schnelligkeit geht auch in dieser so
großen frage der pandemie bekämpfung des
des corona virus und die zweite sache
die auf die hier sehr deutlich
hingewiesen wird vor allem auch heute an
diesem tag wohl jetzt klar ist wie das
verfahren für die eu weiter geht ist
dass dieser vorsprung den die briten
haben von zwei wochen oder vielleicht
sind es am ende auch drei wochen in der
pandemie bekämpfung am ende keinen
großen unterschied macht entscheidend
ist ja was im laufe der nächsten monate
an impfdosen verfügbar ist und wie viele
impfungen dann sagen wir mal im ersten
quartal 2021 stattfinden ob jetzt in
diesen ersten oder letzten dezembertagen
die briten vielleicht einen kleinen
vorsprung haben oder auch die usa gegen
der gegenüber der eu das wird keinen
großen unterschied machen für die akuten
fragen im moment von lock down und von
kontakt beschränkung entscheidend ist
wie die nächsten monate weiter gehen und
wenn die eu hier sicher stellt was sie
versprochen hat nämlich diese große
dreistellige millionenzahlen an
impfdosen zu erhalten und dann auch zu
verkämpfen dann glaube ich wird das
große versprechen einzuhalten seien
im ersten in der ersten hälfte 2021 oder
zumindest im frühsommer wieder so weit
zu sein dass man über lockdown maßnahmen
nicht mehr große befinden muss vielen
dank stefan leifert für diese
einschätzung
nach brüssel dankeschön stefan ja und
die frage wie gut das funktioniert in
den nächsten wochen und monaten hängt
natürlich auch davon ab wie gut die
impfzentren funktionieren davon gibt es
mehrere bereits in deutschland dutzende
in den einzelnen bundesländern auf zdf
heute können sie sich auch anschauen in
welchen bundesländern wie viele und wo
es gibt allein in bayern gibt es zum
beispiel mehr als 90 und dazu kommen
noch einzelne mobile in gruppen die dann
in die pflegeheime gehen um dort die
menschen impfen zu können
eines davon steht auch in bingen das
impfzentrum mainz-bingen hier in
rheinland pfalz und matthias hirsch der
leiter des dortigen zentrums zeigt uns
wie man dort im moment aufgestellt ist
wir sind eigentlich im moment
betriebsbereit
wir warten auf den impfstoff ansonsten
personal steht zur verfügung und auch
das medizinische equipment steht bereit
wir werden jetzt in den nächsten tagen
intensiv das personal schulen
der im prozess muss entsprechend
vermittelt werden wir müssen die
prozesse entsprechend noch abstimmen und
verfeinern
durch die lernkurve daneben hinten
hinterher effektiver arbeiten zu können
tja das personal steht zur verfügung
nach einschätzung vieler experten wird
das ein knackpunkt bei der pandemie
bekämpfung sein und man muss gucken dass
man für die vorbereiteten impfzentren
wenn die impfdosen denn dann alle da
sind auch genügend personal findet die
das überhaupt alles leisten können wenn
der impfstoff denn da es wie läuft es
dann in einem solchen impfzentrum
abkommens an der bund liefert auf seine
kosten den impfstoff an die
verteilungszentren in den bundesländern
die mengen je nach einwohnerzahl die
länder und landkreise organisieren ihre
impfzentren unabhängig zusätzlich werden
auch mobile teams in heimen und
krankenhäusern unterwegs sein
hilfe bekommen sie von den krankenkassen
finanziell und organisatorisch alle zu
impfenden werden vorher noch einmal
aufgeklärt untersucht und können sich
hinterher dort ausruhen
einige daten zum verabreichen impfstoff
und zur geimpften personen sollen
zentral an das robert koch institut
gemeldet werden der individuelle name
dabei verschlossen solange der impfstoff
noch relativ knapp ist und stark gekühlt
werden muss findet alles erst mal in den
impfzentren statt
so soll auch ein geordneter durchlauf
der doppelten impfungen und der zügige
verbrauch des impfstoffs gewährleistet
werden ein fläschchen reicht für mehrere
info im laufe der zeit soll auch wieder
die hausärztinnen selbst impfen können
einzeldosen die kasse zahlt in pandemie
zeiten ein weiteres stück normalität
tja und doktor till koch ist wieder bei
uns facharzt für innere medizin teil des
teams der infektiologie am uniklinikum
hamburg eppendorf und außerdem betreibt
der infektion pott de einen podcast über
infektionskrankheiten hdr kocht die
erste bevölkerungsgruppe die geimpft
werden soll sind alte menschen was
wissen sie über die wirksamkeit die
effektivität des wirkstoffes des
impfstoffes gerade in dieser
bevölkerungsgruppe genau ja schön dass
wieder ein
ich hatte schon in der letzten woche
zwei publikationen in fachzeitschriften
erschienen zu 2 1 von diesen drei
erfordert also von den impfstoffen am
weitesten entwickelt worden sind
der wert ist der impfstoff der paybox
impfstoffforschung der astrazeneca
gruppe entwickelt wurde und der zweite
den wert heute war auch sprechen wollen
weil er am ehesten in deutschland als
erstes fällt in der feuerwehr und
klebstoff also dieser auf trainer
basierte impfstoff wer ist da sind die
daten im channel sind also in einer
angesehensten fakten welt medizinisch
veröffentlicht worden und das hat
vereinen bestätigt was wir schon wussten
über die effektivität das sind nämlich
in den allermeisten gruppen an den 95
prozent beträgt also schutz vor 19
und darin aber ein paar andere ganz
interessante sagte auch noch dabei
gekommen und eine um jetzt auch diese
frage zu antworten ist eben dass gruppen
anscheinend eben genau so gut geschützt
sind bei der zwei eine der großen fragen
die wir uns vorgestellt haben
besonders wohl gerade in populationen
also die besonders betroffenen gruppen
von branchen die besonders schwer
häufig besonders schwer erkranken dann
guckt nur die eine chance haben daran zu
sterben sind gegen vor allem sind die
auch genauso gut geschützt und in dieser
ersten studie zum beispiel eine gruppe
von über 75 jährigen und da stehen die
effektivität eben genau so war ein ganz
wichtiges wirklich neues finding einig
die neue erkenntnis die ich jetzt auch
etwas dieser fachpublikationen gewonnen
hat
herr doktor koche ich muss an der stelle
uns entschuldigen weil die qualität der
übertragung leider nicht so besonders
gut ist ich weiß nicht ob ihre nachbarn
gerade alle zu viel netflix gucken oder
ganz auf jeden fall müssen wir damit
leben dass bild und ton ein bisschen
besser sein könnten nichtsdestotrotz
versuche ich mal eine frage eines users
an sie weiterzugeben bzw
es ist ein ziemlich klares statement ein
user namens es ist der kürzeste
usernamen der mir bisher hier
untergekommen ist sagt wenn die ema den
impfstoff überhaupt zulässt wenn sie
verantwortlich handeln dann erteilen sie
keine zulassung denn anhand der
datenlage ist das risiko so hoch wie
seinen nutzen nebenwirkungen wie 40 grad
fieber körper schmerzen kopfschmerzen
oder allergische reaktionen sind nicht
so harmlos wie man tut was antworten sie
die zulassung die bis jetzt erfolgt sind
und so habe ich das auch verstanden dass
es bei immer auch darum geht sind ja
keine ganz normalen zulassung so das ist
wie ein normaler start mit für immer und
ewig zu gewissen ist sondern im fernen
notfall zulassung und das hat eben auch
ein grund warum man wird zu dieser not
bei zulassung die eben deutlich
schneller geht als eine normale
zulassung entscheidet und dass es eben
die gesamte dazu der wir uns befinden
und dass wir eine weltweite pandemie
haben der auch in deutschland im moment
jeden tag über 100 leute starren sterben
am 19
und angesichts dessen ist es eben eine
abwägungssache auf der einen seite muss
man eben das etwas limitierte wissen was
man über den impfstoff abwägen und eben
das risiko an den coup 19 zu sterben und
da ganz klar pro impfung ausgesetzt so
nebenwirkungen die da angesprochen
worden sind gibt es die werden auch in
diesem artikel beschrieben aber die sind
jetzt nicht so häufig wieder angegeben
wurde
also dass alle häufigsten nebenwirkungen
zum beispiel bei diesem fall dabei und
impfstoff sind schmerzen an der
einstichstelle also lokale erst dort wo
ich gekämpft wurde
und du musst schnell fehlten auch
aufgetreten und dann ist auch noch so
etwas wie abgeschlagenheit
fertig wird das land ungefähr der hälfte
der fälle aufgetreten und auch so
kopfschmerzen waren relativ häufig das
war aber nur ungefähr 50%
abgeschlagenheit und kopfschmerzen und
ungefähr einem drittel der fälle auch in
der placebogruppe das heißt so ein
riesengroßer unterschied war da nicht
dazwischen und die wenig schwere
nebenwirkungen sogenannte serious
adverse events wie wir das nennen sind
bei all diesen 10.000 geimpften der
welten also enorm groß so was wie 0,5
prozent oder suchen behaupten
aufgetreten zur wirkungsweise des
impfstoffs fragt uns per e-mail
christiane engel warum musste er also es
keine frage zur wirkungsweise sondern
quasi zum umgang damit warum muss der
impfstoff von biontech bei minus 75 grad
gelagert werden
genau also das scheint tatsächlich neuen
technologie der impfstoffherstellung
also die nehrener basierten impfstoffen
daran zu liegen weil das ist ja auch
nicht nur bei einer sondern bei moderner
bei dem anderen inneren arbeiten im
stoppen
man kann vereinfacht vereinfacht sagen
dass diese rna die da drin ist so eine
art fährt lädchen verpackt die
degradiert also die geht kaputt werden
sie zu lange bei raumtemperatur ist bei
den pfeilen stoffverdeck muss zwar
transportiert werden bei minus 70 grad
minus 80 grad
der kann aber durchaus auch fünf tage so
sagt der hersteller bei
kühlschranktemperatur bei vier grad
gelagert werden den partnern durchaus
ein bisschen spielraum aber daran liegt
dass also der technologie bekundet
es gibt zwei fragen die sehr spezifisch
auf risikogruppen ausgerichtet sind ich
fast sie gerade mal zusammen per e-mail
fragt sonja hammer
wir haben eine 13 jährige tochter die an
mukoviszidose erkrankt ist also zur
risikogruppe gehört würden sie eine
impfung für jugendliche empfehlen
beziehungsweise raten sie aufgrund der
chronischen erkrankung zur impfung er ab
ich mache da mal ein punkt damit sie die
frage auch wer hat das eine ganz
schwierige frage natürlich also was man
per während die kinder erstmal nicht so
häufig betroffen von korinth dass ich
mal sehr gut aber kinder mit
vorerkrankungen sind potenziell ja
trotzdem vielleicht etwas gefehlt
jetzt ist es so sonst allgemein gesagt
vertragen kinderimpfungen
häufig nicht ganz so gut wie ältere dass
gerade auch leute meistens weniger
nebenwirkungen haben kinder davon
und das ist auch der grund warum man die
impfstoffe am anfang nie in kindern
getestet sondern immer nur in
erwachsenen oder jetzt beyoncés stoff
zum beispiel da hat man ab 16 jahren
leute eingeschlossen und die zulassung
für kinder das wird auch noch dauert es
wahrscheinlich einige monate dauern weil
die studien dazu
die fangen jetzt gerade erst an und
jetzt auf den konkreten fall gewinnen zb
die studien mit zwölfjährigen also zwölf
bis 15 jährigen die fangen jetzt gerade
erst ab und das wird noch einige monate
dauern bis wir da dass wir da eine
aussage haben das heißt auch die
15-jährige personen wird jetzt erstmal
so schnell nicht geimpft werden dann
gibt es eine frage über facebook melike
bildern basa frei gefragt ist der
impfstoff für asthmatiker getestet kann
ich mich ohne bedenken impfen lassen
ja also wenn jemand eine achtmal kann
hat wird jetzt für mich klar gegen eine
impfung sprechen wir müssen wir können
vielleicht auch noch mal auf die anderen
risikogruppen angucken die wir
angesprochen haben die nämlich auch zum
teil zumindest beschrieben wird in
dieser fachgruppe und ich schon erwähnt
hatte die im juli verschieben wurde zum
weinen sind verschiedene gruppen also
unter noch nach anderen parametern
untersucht worden und geschlecht zum
beispiel da war die wirksamkeit gleich
egal ob mann oder frau jetzt zum
beispiel war dann aber auch nach
vorerkrankungen insbesondere oder
übergewicht und bluthochdruck als ford
kranken beschrieben und auch da hatte
ich keine schlechtere verträglichkeit
und auch keine schlechtere wirksamkeit
gezeigt andere gruppen direkt im spiel
schwer immunsystem unterdrückten
personen also immunsupprimierten
personen die irgendwelche
grunderkrankungen verziert oder so haben
die waren da jetzt erstmal noch nicht
eingeschlossen und auch schwangere
personen waren da aus vorsichtsgründen
sozusagen dieser ersten studie jetzt
noch nicht eingeschlossen
das sind aber gruppen die jetzt bestimmt
auch in den nächsten monaten getestet
werden ich würde gerne zum abschluss
noch eine frage nach dem timing stellen
denn da gibt es vereinzelt aus der
politik auch aussagen also wenn der
impfstoff da ist und die zulassung da
ist dann spricht nichts dagegen dass die
lokalen behörden
dann auch entscheiden über die
weihnachtsfeiertage schon zu impfen das
heißt auch am 24 25 26
wäre das personal oder die leute die da
eben sich dafür bereit erklärt haben zu
impfen gefordert um auch an den
feiertagen zu impfen
was glauben sie wann geht es hier in
deutschland los also ich glaube da bin
ich auf die gleichen informationen www
an gewähren nämlich so geblieben
verlautbarungen und genau ich habe jetzt
gehört das am 21
entschieden werden soll und ich glaube
dann könnte potenziell an 22 not klären
es ist ja genau es gab ja auch wie der
kollege vorhin schon gesagt hat es kommt
jetzt da nicht so sehr in der gesamten
partei ich meinem frühjahr wollten alle
die impfungen haben ein paar wochen als
der laden dort kamen alle gesagt das
geht ein bisschen schnell und im moment
jetzt gerade rollen aber ganz schnell
wieder die impfung haben das ist ja gut
absitzt ist ein paar tage dauert das
endeffekt nicht so einen großen
unterschied
und dann ist er tatsächlich da der
impfstoff und das ist eine gute
nachricht und die haben wir bitter nötig
in diesen tagen vielen dank dr till koch
für das gespräch nach hamburg und wie
gesagt für die schlechte qualität
entschuldigen wir uns an dieser stelle
und das wird sicher nicht das letzte
gespräch gewesen sein dass wir zu dem
thema miteinander geführt haben vielen
dank an sie und auch vielen dank an alle
userinnen und user fürs zuhören und
mitmachen und ihnen allen einen guten
abend tschüss